merci la parole et à monsieur david
douillet merci monsieur le président je
m'associe à ma question
mon collègue et ami monsieur jean
françois lamour monsieur le ministre
chargé des sports
je tiens à saluer l'action du comité de
candidature paris 2024 co-présidée par
le mouvement sportif à travers tony
estanguet bernard la passe et est
activement soutenue par notre membre du
cio guy drut
il ya dix jours date de la remise du
troisième et dernier dossier de
candidature au cio
nous avons assisté à l'ouverture de la
période de promotion internationale de
la candidature de paris pour accueillir
les jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
2024 notre pays possède une longue
tradition d'accueil et d'organisation
d'événements sportifs internationaux
ce savoir est reconnu mondialement
les jeux sont bien plus qu'une simple
compétition sportive parce qu'il permet
d'impulser une vraie dynamique nationale
et pas seulement économiques ni même
médiatique ou touristiques
n'en déplaise aux mauvaises langues il
constitue un grand projet national qui
fédère toute une nation et disons le
franchement nous avons nous en avons
grand besoin
arrogance projet autocentré
surexposition des personnalités
politiques ou encore sous-estimation de
l'importance de la promotion
internationale de la candidature
nous avons collectivement tirer les
leçons des échecs passés en fédérant
pour 2024
le soutien de l'ensemble du mouvement
sportif des acteurs institutionnels et
de la société civile
je profite de l'occasion qui m'est
donnée pour vous inviter mes chers
collègues à diffuser très largement le
slogan de notre campagne de promotion
internationale en français venez
partager en anglais med farine
monsieur le ministre nous entrons dans
la dernière ligne droite de la
candidature il est très important que
chacun sache où nous en sommes
pouvez vous nous dresser un point
d'étape sur les chances de la france et
de la candidature parisienne de
l'emporter et les grandes échéances à
venir avant la décision des membres du
comité international olympique
merci la parole étant monsieur thierry
braillard secrétaire d'état chargée des
sports monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires monsieur
david douillet en marche de votre
question je vais quand même rappeler que
vous êtes double champion olympique de
judo et que jean-françois lamour et
double champion olympique de sabre
c'est une candidature la créature de
paris solide et sur de bons rails comme
vous l'avez rappelé le président de la
république a souhaité que le mouvement
sportif porte cette candidature c'est la
raison pour laquelle tony estanguet
bernard lapasset président le comité de
candidature avec le soutien affiché de
guy drut membre du cio
par ailleurs vous savez que notre pays
ces dernières années et peut-être le
pays au monde qui accueillit le plus
d'événements sportifs internationaux qui
ont donné satisfaction
ce qui prouve notre attractivité et ce
qui prouve aussi notre savoir faire
alors maintenant pourra être candidat
aux jeux olympiques et paralympiques ya
trois dossiers à remettre le premier sur
le concept des jeux a été remis le
deuxième sur le montage juridique et
financier a également été remis et le 3
février dernier
c'est le dossier sur l'organisation de
la manifestation qui a été remis une
tomate bar le président du cio a relevé
l'unité de cette candidature et je
voulais déjà remercié l'ensemble des
groupes parlementaires qui ont décidé de
soutenir tous ensemble paris 2024 tout
comme le travail remarquable de madame
hidalgo la maire de paris tout comme le
soutien de valérie pécresse au saut avec
le conseil régional d'île de france et
un gouvernement entièrement mobilisée
thomas ce bar a dit que ceux qui
l'avaient surpris ce qu'il avait
impressionné c'était l'unité de cette
candidature
qu'est ce qui nous reste du 13 au 16 mai
la visite du comité d'évaluation le 23
juin j'habite tout le monde à une grande
mobilisation populaire pour la journée
des jeux et enfin le 13 septembre à lima
j'espère que de l'envelope sortira le
nom de paris je relate irait bien